alter schwede was war das denn junge
skates und herzlich willkommen 209 folge
zuschauer überrascht und wie gehen wie
immer auf meinen teamspeak ver.di das
war das als kraftstoff für das format
nicht kennen das format funktioniert so
ich bin auf mein eigen teamspeak
unterwegs escape tv und superrennen
leute aus mit denen die spiele die ich
sozusagen bisschen überraschen
deswegen auch zuschauer überrascht und
ich würde sagen wir sind einfach mal
direkt rein jetzt schon der lobby mit
zwei leuten ich hab grad noch kirschen
oder eistiger professionell ganz okay
wir gehen hier ein ok 321 nicht viel was
man machen kann damit nicht mehr so
schadet man kann eine runde 64er tsg
spielen natürlich auch was haltet ihr
davon
sondern das machen so leute wir uns
jetzt alle zusammen gefunden
ich stell dir mal vor wir sind in der
runde drin wir mussten gerade ein
bisschen newton weil die ein bisschen
mehr probleme mit dem zaun hatten eine
waffe wieder laufen oder machen wir es
gelaufen
sie sieht mich jemand die filter sind
vorbei irgend jemand ok ok aber süchtig
region sehr schön sehr schön die kiste
den hier
ich habe einen fall und einen bogen um
natur kennt man im ferrari target
ausgetragen
oh ja da seht ihr schon zwei von den
leuten mit den wortspielen harry und
dort india sascha und einen komplexen
der dritte
wie viel spielt zusammen und die renten
sind gegner lass mal schauen was sie
können oder sind zweierteam voll
eingezogen sie wollen wir alle mal
zusammen hoch zum hangar gehen ich
glaube es besser treffen beim hunger
kann ich locker chen glitschig ist schon
dann als erstes von dann sehr schön
okay leute ihr habt gerade eben schon
gesagt dass mit volvo ist scheiße alter
richtig scheiße ich kann es für alle
sagen leute
es hat mich einfach wirklich richtig
fertig gemacht ich hab mich richtig
richtig schlecht gefühlt danach als
werden also so schlecht wie man sich
fühlt wenn wirklich was schiefläuft
unternehmen im eigenen leben also wenn
man irgendwie kanal richtige prüfung
verpackt oder so oder wenn keine alle
wisst schon was ich meine wenn man sich
schlecht fühlt so ging es mir da hier
das hab ich hab ich so noch nicht gesagt
ich weiß nicht ob man das in der folge
sich denken konnte in der folge habe ich
noch gar nicht gedacht ehrlich gesagt
das war zu kurz an sprechen und
natürlich wie immer gerne ein wolf in
essen so dass da lassen wir haben noch
nicht so richtig losgelegt immer mit den
worten obwohl der andere angeblich nur
mit freundeskreis foto hat er 43 750 da
geht bestimmt noch was haut auch gerne
noch mal rein okay jetzt zurück zu runde
hat jemand ich habe hat jemand übrigen
compass mit dem er auch jeder nennen
raus
dies nimmt die kiste ich gucke mir das
ist das leben der waffe handle
ach ich weiß nicht was da für leute habt
ihr vielleicht einen guten tipp für ein
hotkey wo ich meine man fährt ins team
machen könnte
aber ich habe ein ff drücke wenn ich
automatisch slot 8
dann packe ich das feld pak ich habe
auch so ein fsj ich habe mein erstes tor
freuen aber ich musste da bist du bist
du lebst du leute da blick alter gigi
und heißt diese junge band ihren sg
gesehen ja es ist okay also leute die
info es gibt fehlern in den kisten und
diese neu die neon fehlen
ich glaub ich glaube es dauert noch bis
ich mir dass die jugend stadt
eingewöhnen
mit dem f naja egal ich habe bisher halt
nur mit zahlen gearbeitet also nur mit
134 sorge war okay lol lol ich weiß
nicht wie das blatt gesetzt habe ich hab
keinen rechtsklick gemacht krass
vielleicht habe ich auf den secret
rechtsklick das pulver einer von euch so
bis 1
groovy von der bast scho plastikpuppen
man kann auch nicht erwarten dass man
das dass ihr irgendwie ein super micro
haupt aber das ist halt so ein format
ist wissen die zuschauer auch so ist das
nun mal schauen wo hier der nächste
gegner zeitig muss dringend was essen
nach einer kästen ist meine gäste hier
hoch gehen kommen hier hoch ich hab hier
oben gibt es einiges an christen hier
ist was stick realschülern die räume
reingehen ihr dürft eigentlich
eigentlich einiges geben glaube ich fast
dass ich habe meinen reisen korrekter
gefühlen heim
sonst können wir auf jeden fall schon
mal reisen stellt klopfen
noch einer von euch sprechen dir ja ich
könnte theoretisch auch noch mal kurz
entsorgen und zwar das hier ja okay dann
warte daten kompass war ich nämlich raus
alles ok soweit sie gegner angreifen
oder weißt du wo es langgeht ich wollte
einfach fragte einfach da ist von so was
habe ich als selten arno leute obwohl
ich eigentlich die maps recht oft spiele
weil sich nur selten das mal gucken was
sie haben diesen mega weit weg aber ich
weiß offene die welt noch ganz andere
angegriffen okay geben erst mal dass man
zum strand kräften machen fahrzeug sehr
schön sehr schön
ja ich glaub ich weiß das zu meistern
ja ich sehe es schon jetzt schon das
crafting teil ok sehr gut darunter einer
leute ich hab euch noch gar nicht
vorgestellt sagt er ich noch am leben in
der runde
okay aber ja ich würde sagen reihum
angefangen verkaufen um nach unten jason
ricci dann sascha sag mal kurz wer ihr
seid also ich kenne ja wahrscheinlich
schon fast schon mal dabei beide
zuschauer überrascht bin ich außerdem
ein geplatzt
es musste also dessen ist ein ort von
mir da kann ich immer die forschung
übernehmen
mit auftritten so schon langjähriger
zuschauer und ein flyer boy und
regierung
bärbel studie ich bin ein freund von
krisen ein rennen schon sehr lange und
dich hab ich auch schon mal gesehen
und sascha man versteht es wie kaum
bistro von jason mackenzie woher uhr
zwischen die haben uns ja komplett
rasiert alter was hat das mit
überraschungsattacke ist alles klar
alter schwede aber reg dich jetzt ein
leben gekostet
okay aber ich habe jetzt ein schwert
habe ich am start
okay okay auch in steinheim sehr gut
dann könnt ihr vielleicht in leggings
anziehen sollte sich an ergeben mal
genau dass man so aussortieren
dann werfen uns nicht gegenseitig noch
mehr
ok ich muss aber ich noch mal schauen
also so richtig weggeworfen
aber so hat ihn auf es wird bei mir gar
nicht jetzt spontan da muss ich pack's
glaub ich lieber auf die 32 gegner jeder
ein
du bist von den leuten angenommen
aber ich bin gut ich habe mich
gegenseitige kiel und der anderen
gewonnen
alter schwede was war das denn junge wie
unwahrscheinlich ist das denn wird die
haben sich echt nicht schlecht
angestellt muss man sagen ja ich würde
sagen das passt aber ihr fall so danke
an euch fürs dabei sein
also noch mal jason regel uns
wahrscheinlich spitzenleute werde diese
dann schlägt sofort deren sitzen und
lassen
wir sind zwar nächste video macht's gut